[Music]
what's up guys mkbhd here and Android q
letter Q is now out and in beta and this
version not a big visual overhaul which
is kind of what the big letter updates
used to be and I missed that a bit but
this is definitely full of a lot of
smaller updates that people who use
Android a lot will appreciate so I got
Android q beta one on my pixel two
available on pixels for now all the way
back to the first gen pixel but it is a
beta and there's some things that are
not stable about it so I wouldn't put
this on your main device but if you want
to try it I'll link it below so number
one there are some light theming options
which is pretty cool so in the settings
if you go to settings advanced developer
options and then go all the way scroll
all the way the bottom there's a theming
section with a couple of options accent
color font and icon shape so accent
color is kind of cool there's a couple
built-in options I like the black
but there's also a green and a purple
and when you change the color you can
see reflected in the menus and the quick
settings and toggles and everything it's
not exactly an RGB selector tool it's
not totally custom so you can't pick
whatever color you want but it's more
than just the default blue which is cool
then you can change the default system
font if you want
if someone's into that and then the icon
shape is also kind of interesting so you
can change between the normal circle
that it typically is to a teardrop a
skwerkel or a rounded rectangle and each
option when you select it will change
the icon shape for the icons that are on
your homescreen and in your app drawer
and in your quick settings so anywhere
there's icons basically I actually don't
hate the teardrop or the skwerkel which
is the square circle but the rectangle
was a little boring for me but hey the
option is there also we still don't know
if dark mode is gonna be a thing in
android natively but look what happens
when you go into battery saver mode in
Android queue when you toggle it you
automatically get basically a
system-wide dark theme even more than an
Android Pi so it darkens the quick
settings and the app drawer and
everything else and which is of course
gonna help save battery on OLED displays
but also looks pretty cool now this is
battery saver mode so you probably not
want to leave it on all the time because
you lose some features and things in
battery saver mode but the fact that it
does all that automatically still is
something to keep an eye on
number two there's even more granular
control of app permissions it's
thrilling stuff but honestly it is
pretty important and kind of overdue so
now with things like location for
example the first time you open an app
that requests your location you can set
it to be on all the time never or only
when the app is running so basically
like iOS I'm glad that options here and
there's number three new notification
behavior just first swiping just four
swipe direction so an Android P or any
other previous version you can dismiss
notifications by swiping left or right
however you want but then to adjust
notification settings or mute something
you have to do this slightly awkward
like half swipe that was kind of easy to
mess up not a huge deal but they're
fixing that with Android Q so now
notifications only dismiss little swipe
to the right and a swipe to the left is
just for settings so now no matter how
far you swipe it's that more definitive
which each direction does also it's much
more like iOS again so number four the
new share sheet and this may seem like
one of those little tiny things but if
you've used Android for more than about
a week you already know this is a huge
deal so every version of Android up
until now if you wanted to share
something you hit share and it brings up
the share sheet with all the places to
send it to then after a massive delay it
also brings some quick sharing options
from apps to use frequently but that
delay is painful and annoying to wait
for every single time and if you're
trying to share something real quick you
can hit share and then go to press an
app but then the quick share options
load up on top of it and it moves what
you were about to press so you press
something else by accident I swear I do
this every single day in Android q this
is cleaned up share shortcuts now all
load at once which is a beautiful thing
over and over it's such a small detail
but I cannot wait to never have to deal
with the old share sheet ever again then
number five last but not least is all
the little things just a bunch of little
stuff piled together it's kind of the
theme of this update it's what Android Q
is all about so there's a new and
improved files app better looking more
organized just overall better than the
last one you get a bit more battery
information so if you enable battery
percentage visible it'll also show you
when it thinks your battery will run out
based on how much time it thinks you
have left
so in those quick settings I don't know
how much you can trust that but
hey if it's a pretty good estimate
that's better than nothing you can now
also undo removing things from the home
screen so it's such a small detail but
if you remove like a big custom widget
or something by accident you can easily
just undo it to put it back exactly
where it was without having to remember
how to set it all up again no stress
lock screen album art it's now blurred a
lot when playing music which looks
cleaner but it's maybe a little too
blurred I feel like I'd prefer somewhere
in the middle between these then there's
also now behind the scenes support for
foldable phones which are coming sooner
than you think and there's also now this
super smooth animation for turning off
the display and going into that
always-on mode now I've never been a
person to leave on the always-on display
but that animation is pretty slick oh
also there's now a built-in native
Android screen recorder barely sorta I
mean it's kind of super buggy I don't
even know if I can say this really
exists yet but I'm just gonna show it to
you anyway so if you dive into settings
system advanced and developer options
then you got a scroll until you find
something called feature flags then in
feature flags scroll until you find one
called
enable settings screen record long press
and just make sure that is checked it's
not by default once this is checked if
you want to screen record you long press
the power button then long press the
screenshot button and there you go that
gives you the option to start a screen
recording and you can also turn on or
off audio and show screen touches if you
want which is handy and then start and
then it's going so you get a
notification drop-down that says you're
recording and you can go about using the
phone just like normal while the screen
recording goes this is one of my
favorite features from iOS they recently
added it although with this one now you
can choose to show screen touches and do
audio recording at the same time you can
do a whole tutorial with this that's
pretty cool
the one minor detail is I haven't been
able to get screen recordings to stop
recording yet so you know it's kind of a
deal breaker but that's a small detail
like the stop button crashes the UI the
pause button also crashes the whole app
and the cancel button just straight up
doesn't work either so
no matter what I try it just kind of
crashes and everything comes back and
the screen recording is still going so
the only way I could get it to stop was
to restart the whole phone and then the
video would never actually show up in my
gallery so again beta this is beta one
but I'm hoping Frehley really hoping
that this gets built out into its own
feature and Android actually having a
screen recording built in would be
pretty sweet also speaking of screen
recordings screen shots in android q on
the pixel now have a cutout for the
knotch
built into this screen shot why I don't
know there's also corners on the screen
shot too like the rounded corner shows
up can't say I saw that coming as a
feature but hey at least now you know
when you get a screen shot from someone
that they definitely have a notch on
their phone but that's basically it
that's uh that's mainly what's new with
Android q there's some good stuff again
a lot of smaller things and not a whole
lot of visual refresh I could put these
side by side next to each other and you
probably wouldn't notice unless I told
you but uh who knows which phones will
ever actually get Android q most
flagships coming out now are just
getting P now peppermint but peppermint
why does it peppermint it's pi I also
don't know what the Q is actually gonna
stand for I tried to think of Q desert
names I literally don't know any like I
know quiche and I know what like
quesadillas q-tip these aren't even
foods anymore maybe leave your comment
below what you think the Q is gonna
stand for also shoutout to Android
police for their constantly updated
feature list of things that they dig
through Android Q and fine they have all
the things I've talked about and many
more little things so I'll link that
below that's pretty much it thank you
for watching
catch you guys in the next one peace